-Our next guest is
a talented actor and comedian
you know from his work on
"The Daily Show" and "Evil."
His new panel show,
"Would I Lie to You?",
airs Saturdays on The CW.
Let's take a look.
-If this is a lie, you didn't
need to do the horse-meat bit.
Like, we didn't need that.
-Do you mind if I talk to
my client for a second?
[ Laughter ]
-Sure.
-Off mic.
-I'm getting hot.
-I would say...
-I suppose a falcon or...
-Well, horse meat
is a brand of bird seed.
-No! See? See?
Brooke Shields, if this is true,
you win the entire show.
-Yeah.
-Please welcome back to the show
Aasif Mandvi, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show!
-Thank you.
Thanks for having me back.
-It a long time --
We were talking backstage.
A long time
since you've been here.
And the last couple of years,
giant life change.
-Giant. Giant.
Well, for all of us.
Oh, you mean my baby?
-Yeah, you had a baby.
-I had a child.
-Yeah. We all had your child.
-All I think about
is the pandemic.
-Yeah. That's very exciting.
So, how old? Boy, girl?
-Boy. A boy.
-Okay. Yeah.
-And he's 2 years old.
He just turned 2.
He was born on March 14th,
like three days before
New York went into lockdown.
-Yeah, that's -- Somebody loved
the lockdown.
-Exactly.
-"Whoo!"
-"Lockdown!"
-Is your birthday March 14th?
-Whoo!
-Yeah. Great. Okay.
-They're very -- they're not --
They're not
the best communicators, yeah.
Also, like, like, really
lukewarm on their birthday.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I've had some good ones
and some bad ones.
So, you have a 2-year-old.
This is -- I feel like
personalities are in bloom now?
-Oh, my gosh.
He -- Yeah, I mean, he's great.
You know, I waited till
I was older to have a child,
and so it's great, 'cause I get
to really be with him
and spend time with him.
And the other day, I went into
his room in the morning,
and he sat up
and he went, "Poop!"
And I was like, "Oh, great," you
know, "You've done a poop?
That's great
you're communicating
and telling me that you pooped."
I put him on the changing table,
I open his diaper, nothing.
And I said, "Ishan,
you didn't do a poop."
And he looks at me
and he goes, "Joking you."
-Oh. Jackpot.
-I was like --
-Jackpot.
-I was like, "That's solid.
That is a solid joke."
-Yeah, like, level one.
That's a good level-one joke.
-Absolutely. I mean,
we can get into the whole
"lying is not joking"
kind of thing later,
but for right now,
they're solid.
He did a thing the other day
where he's now learned the song,
you know...
♪ Red and yellow
and pink and blue ♪
So, he was singing that
and then he just looks at me
and he goes, "Now funny way."
And I was like, "Okay."
And he just started going...
♪ Red and yellow and pink...♪
And I was like,
"Again, solid joke."
-I love it.
It's like he's, like, working on
a lounge-singer act, yeah.
-He's got a
whole -- By the time he's 3,
he's going on the road.
-This is very nice.
So, I also started later
as a dad,
and I think it's true,
like, the great thing is,
there's nothing in your life --
Like, no one --
if you didn't have a kid,
no one would want to
hang out with you anyway.
-Right, right.
-'Cause you're too old.
-Yes, exactly.
And I don't go out any -- Well,
we had enjoyed the pandemic,
so it was actually
kind of weirdly great.
Like, we were sort of in
a bubble of having a child,
and the whole world was
in a bubble, you know?
And so we didn't have any FOMO
or any of that stuff.
But it's been really amazing,
'cause I've just gotten to spend
a lot of really
quality time with him.
-That's excellent.
Yeah, we have to find
silver linings.
So, this show that you have on
The CW right now --
this is based on a British show.
-It's based on
a British show, yes.
-And when did you
discover this show?
-So, this was -- 2019, I started
watching this British --
I'm obsessed with,
like, British shows,
'cause I grew up in England.
So I watch BritBox.
Like, I'm an addict.
-Yep, I love
a good BritBox show.
-I watched this show called
"Would I Lie to You?"
on the British -- BritBox,
and I fell in love with it.
And I started --
And my wife and I would watch it
at the end of the day,
because it was
during the Trump administration,
and, frankly, you know,
we needed something
to get us through it.
-Yeah. Like, at some point,
you're like,
"Let's watch British celebrities
lie to each other," yeah.
-So it was just a way to laugh
and have fun
at the end of the night.
And so I actually told
Robert King,
who is the creator and executive
producer of the show "Evil"
that I'm also on --
I told him about it,
and he started watching it
and fell in love with it
and then came to me and said,
"Why don't we do an
American version of this show."
And, you know, as an Indian,
person of Indian descent,
I am more than happy to
steal something from
the British anytime...
-It's time to, like,
even the score a little bit.
-...that I can.
I'm like, "I'll take that."
-You're owed a couple.
-I am. I am.
-But that's interesting,
though, like,
you bringing a British
sensibility here,
because you mentioned
you grew up in England.
-Yeah.
-And then you --
How old were you?
You moved to Florida, right?
-I moved to Tampa, Florida,
when I was 16.
-16.
-Yes.
Yeah, anybody, anybody?
No, not one person.
-And you were sort of like --
I would imagine, like,
Northern England to Florida
is a real leap.
-Really? You think so?
-Yeah.
A good stylistic leap.
And at 16, like, you're not --
I mean, you're kind of who
you are at that point, like...
-Yeah. Well, yeah.
I went from a coal-mining,
Northern, gray English town
to Tampa, Florida,
which, you know --
And it was interesting,
because when I got to America,
I often joked that,
like, Americans think about
the rest of the world the way
New Yorkers think about
the rest of America.
-Yeah.
-Like, they don't, you know?
And, so, I got here, and people
didn't really know what I was.
They thought I was Australian.
They thought I was,
you know, Lebanese.
They didn't know.
So, but it was funny, because
when I first got to America,
I was thrown into
this American high school,
and I was just, you know,
this little English boy
in an all-American
sort of high school.
And I just remember I made this
friend after a couple of days
in high school.
It was, like, not really --
I've never spoken to
the guy again,
but it was two days --
He was my friend after two days.
And while I was talking to him,
he suddenly said,
"Okay, well,
I'm gonna take off."
And I remember, like, my little
English brain was just like,
"You're going to take off?
What do you mean?"
And I just could not fathom
this or understand it.
We had a teacher who
said to me -- And this must --
-Did you think he was gonna
have, like, a jet pack?
-I thought he was gonna
literally take off right there.
Like, I was like, "Do you mean
you're gonna take off
right now?"
But -- And then we had
a teacher who --
And this must be
a Southern thing.
I don't know if anybody here
is from the South.
But she wanted me to take my pen
and put it up,
which means put it away.
It's a Southern vernacular.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And she said that to me,
and I literally took the pen
and I didn't know what --
and I just put it above my head.
And she sent me to detention.
-Yeah, it's funny.
Like, that's a tough --
Like, 16's tough,
'cause, like, it's not --
You're not, like,
a charming British scamp.
It's like,
"Who's this 16-year-old..."
-Yeah, I tried to work the
English accent for a while.
-Did people ask you
things about England?
What did people from Tampa think
an English person would know?
-Well, they thought
I knew The Beatles.
Like, it was -- You know, it was
the '80s, and I think they --
They were just like,
"Have you ever met any of them?"
And I'm like,
"Yes, that's right. I have."
And I was just trying to
work the English angle
for a little while.
I think there were a couple of
girls in my school
who might have been Anglophiles
who appreciated it.
-And then they were like --
Probably by day three,
they were like, "I don't think
this guy knows The Beatles.
I don't think
he's personally met them."
-I think my lack of ability
with ladies, like,
outweighed the fact
that I had an English accent.
-Yeah, they were like,
"I think that guy's
close personal friends with
Paul McCartney,
but it's still not worth it."
You -- So, you --
Did you bring --
Like, when you think back
to, like, your --
you know, for me,
you know, I was lucky,
'cause my parents loved,
like, Monty Python.
I feel like my education was,
like, "SNL."
Was yours the Monty Python
era of British comedy?
-I grew up with Monty Python and
I grew up with "Fawlty Towers"
and all those British sitcoms.
Like, you know,
there was one called
"Not the Nine O'Clock News,"
which Rowan Atkinson
came out of.
So I sort of grew up
with all of that in my head.
And, in fact, when I was a
little kid, I made this, like,
cassette tape that was --
You know, it was back when
you had cassettes,
and you would just talk into
the little tape player.
And I made a tape called
"The Giant Man-Eating Ostrich."
And it was four and a half hours
long of me, as a 10-year-old,
just doing all the characters.
And it was very
Monty Python-esque,
where this ostrich
was just, like,
stomping on all the people in
this village, in this town.
And then my parents
would play it for guests
when they would come over.
-Yeah. When they would
come over for, like,
long dinner parties?
-Yeah, and my dad would be like,
"Look at our son.
Look how talented he is."
And he'd put this thing in,
and you could just see
people's eyes start to water,
because they had to listen to
four and a half hours of some
little English boy going,
"There's a giant
eating ostrich coming.
Oh, mummy!"
And just...
-That's a very proud father.
That's what I'm gonna
take away from this story
is that you have
a very proud father.
-He was very proud of me.
-So, but you actually --
You ruined dinner parties
for years after,
because you actually --
You and Connie Britton,
the wonderful actor --
And I shouldn't say "ruined."
I was being facetious.
-Well, we ruined a few.
We ruined a few.
-You were professional --
You're young actors in New York.
-Mm-hmm. Yeah.
-You would work
murder-mystery dinner parties?
-Murder-mystery dinner parties.
-And so you would go as actors.
-Yes. It was when I first got to
New York and I needed a job,
and they were paying $50 a show.
you know, which was
a solid rate, good rate.
And we'd go out
to a party somewhere
in Jersey or Staten Island or
Long Island somewhere.
And you'd just
sort of pretend like
you were a guest at the party.
And then a hit man would come in
and kill someone.
And then there would
be a detective,
and then the whole thing
would turn into
a murder mystery,
and people would play along.
And that's where I met Connie.
And she and I used to do that
together and make the money.
And there was one -- I don't --
This was a legendary one
where, apparently, they did a
murder mystery in Staten Island,
and I'll just say there were
a lot of guys there named Tony.
-Okay, lot of Tonys, yeah.
-A lot of Tonys, and it was a
guy named Tony's birthday.
And it was
in an Italian restaurant,
and there was some poor actor
who had been hired to be
the hit man
to come in and kill --
"kill" -- another actor
who was hired as the guy
who was gonna get killed.
So, this young actor walks in,
pulls out a gun,
and asks for
the actor who he's gonna shoot,
and 10 guys pulled out pieces.
And everybody hit the deck.
And the actor just urinated
all over himself.
Just shook, dropped the gun,
walked out,
and left the business, I think.
Just never was
seen of again, you know?
-They did give -- They gave him
$55 for that, yeah.
They gave him a little extra
for danger pay.
-And then we worked a singles
party for Orthodox Jews.
That was another one.
And I did that one
with Connie, actually.
She and I was there.
And I said, "How do I pretend to
be an Orthodox Jewish single?"
And they said,
"You're Sephardic.
Just don't worry about it."
And they just stuck
a yarmulke on my head
and had me go out there.
And I was telling --
"Just do an Egyptian accent!"
And then Connie
was playing this very --
You know,
she was Connie Britton,
so she was one of the most
attractive people at this party.
And this poor guy in a yellow --
I remember he
was wearing a yellow suit,
and he was talking
to her all night long
and thought that
he had struck gold.
-And then about, you know,
an hour into the party,
like, she dies.
And I've never seen a man --
Just, like,
his face just collapsed.
But I said, "$1,000 a plate."
-That's fantastic.
You know, that's the thing,
where if you're doing
a murder-mystery party,
prepare your guests.
Prepare your guests, 'cause you
could ruin their evening.
Hey, congratulations on
the new show.
Congratulations on "Evil,"
as well.
I know you've got
Season 3 coming out.
And it's always
so great to see you.
Guys, Aasif Mandvi.
"Would I Lie to You?"
airs Saturdays on The CW.